like when people copied [ __ ] on vine
there was like this like expectation
that you're gonna put like
like inspired by or you're gonna tag the
person who came up with it originally
because if you didn't
the comments were gonna be like you
[ __ ] thieving
piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah you just steal
for yourself and now it's like
yeah just copy like no but yeah sorry
keep going no it's just like your whole
tick tock account can just be what other
people have done
and you can blow up off yeah yeah you
used to have to like do
your own punch line like it would be the
setup for the joke is the same or the
theme is the same but then you would
come up with something
now it's like if you've ever seen that
sound that's like uh
you know oh hot mom with diarrhea check
yeah
yeah yeah addison ray's mom going off on
that one
my hot mom has diarrhea check this on
goal
there's some gold and i'm golden and
golden no it's like it's like uh
you know shawty a little batty she my
little boo
thing and shawty got the fatty shawty
got the fatty
right that one you know that song right
um
yes pop smoke and whoever else yeah okay
so the joke
with that one is there's one there's one
joke that's really funny with that one
it's like the first guy singing shawty
little baddies she my boo thing and then
it's
and then it and then it's like the the
caption is me looking at my
girl at a party and he's like shawty
little baddie she my little boo
thing and then it's like my uncle and
shawty got the fatty
and it's me and then it goes back to me
uh shoddy got the fatty
and then he like he like looks he's like
wait what did my uncle just say
right that's the joke and it's funny the
original is funny and then
i look down the thing and it's like 400
of the
same [ __ ] joke it's just people doing
this
doing the joke yeah over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
it's like no he did and that's how the
50 fans thing comes about dude
where it's like people don't people
never click through to the original
thing yeah
and so um when when the
when that one rando person does it in
the 400 and then like some random people
finally go oh this guy's funny
and it's like then that's how he gets
his 50 fans
you know what i'm saying yeah i see what
you're saying it's like we're in this
weird state
where and i don't want to be all [ __ ]
fake like political science whatever
but it's like humor and entertainment is
so
[ __ ] commodified like it's it's
it's just you can get it from anywhere
you you can be anyone and you're funny
now
or you're a comedian and it's just a
crazy thought that
all these young kids are going to grow
up and their
primary is going to be i want to be
famous
or i want to be known on the internet i
want to entertain
like like like the generation
uh i feel like ahead of them was like oh
i want to be a youtuber you know what i
mean
like that was kind of their idea of it
and they want to be like
emma chamberlain or something where they
vlog and they
see fast cars and they meet funny people
or whatever now like with
tick-tock kids i feel like it's just
like oh yeah i'm just going to get on
tick-tock and
you know it's easy i just do this and
that and i'm super popping
and then you know i get a brand deal and
then i'm not going to go work because
like look at jake paul dude that's me
obviously it's like
i don't know man yeah no i know what
you're saying i know what you're saying
i know i feel like we're being like
boomer right now but
i'm just i want to predict where it's
going to go because like with only fans
and now [ __ ] logan paul has his own
paid fan club that's his
own private patreon jake paul i think is
doing the same thing
and jake paul's gonna [ __ ] his
girlfriend on it yep and
yeah exactly and nelk now does it too
they have the ascend club
yeah yeah okay so where is this like
everyone is just gonna have their own
private little only fans with 50 fans
and you know what comes now is the
[ __ ] and and
to your point about this being boomer
[ __ ] it is boomer [ __ ]
and and that's fine because
i feel like that's the part that is
weird about everyone else
stop pretending you are [ __ ] 12.
you are not 12. all you [ __ ] internet
people you want to get on tick tock and
pretend you're
like nine years old you're not like
you're not
okay you know what i mean it's fine to
say some boomerang [ __ ]
because you are disconnected whether you
like it or not there's some [ __ ]
you just don't get contextually do i
feel like what could happen
is and i feel like it could just be a
relapse of like mcn [ __ ] but it's like
paid
where someone creates a network and they
go
oh uh we we like these guys like these
people like these people and we all have
paid services and we have a way
to simplify that for you we have these
people in-house so you can just do your
thing and we'll take care of this
and you know it might be a hard sell
because everyone will build that up for
themselves and they go what the [ __ ] is
in it for me
but i could see that happening right
like like
or or maybe people group up right and
they create their own
[ __ ] i don't know yeah yeah maybe it
becomes like like a cable network
like you just revert back to like okay
i'm just gonna go to the sway house
channel now okay so i'm gonna go to the
high school
channel exactly and i i pay for packages
and stuff like that
yeah also keep in mind i wanna mention
when i was listing all the full send
club and i was like we do that too right
we have no
patreon yeah and it's
it's just i don't know i love all these
like micro i actually think it's really
cool all these like
micro subscription yeah no it's a good
thing because then it it takes the power
away from like [ __ ]
nbc and whoever these [ __ ] are no
but it's
it can only go so far right eventually
people are gonna be like okay i'm not
gonna pay for this guy's twitch channel
this person's only fans
like my whole [ __ ] monthly salary is
going to these
one person these like you know groups of
one people groups of one people
yeah these different individuals who are
doing different things that i all want
to see
so then what's the solution to that i'm
i don't know man i i think like it
that just might become normal like i
think like that's just what it is like
especially now no no one's going to
[ __ ] live shows
live as far as like value currently
live is being converted into you just
watch it on your phone for free because
you can't do it in person
yeah it's like it's actually this weird
thing where live performances are being
um some some people are doing virtual
right where you pay to see something
virtually
and like that's kind of interesting but
i i feel like
live now is being marketed as like if
you can't be there in person it's not
really worth your money
or it's only worth so much so
with how like i [ __ ] like how starved
some people are
for like entertainment i feel like this
next year and a half is just gonna
completely hammer home the idea of like
oh no i pay this i pay that i pay this i
pay that and these are like my 19
different pieces of entertainment i
think that's just like what it is
that's a wild dude yeah i mean it's
already that way with like hbo max
netflix
hulu espn like people already pay
micro for [ __ ] no i know but these are
these are
giant companies that put millions of
dollars into producing
shows to coax you to get to to pay five
bucks a month for
their service right we're talking about
people that are just
taking their instagrams that they post
for free saving them and then uploading
them to another service and somehow
getting money for that
because titties because boobies
because those sweet milkers that's what
it is
[Laughter]
stop it dude leave that girl alone man
stop
it i know poor girl
i feel really bad i feel really bad but
i can't help i can't not
read the [ __ ] phrase oh bro
i cannot it's not fair no it's not fair
it's not fair i can't read juicy milkers
and not laugh
i can't read milk wagons and not laugh
no it's it's not fair
it's not fair like i'm laughing at her
i'm not laughing at anything i'm just
laughing at me
you see milkers it's absurd man that's
the most deprived
phrase ever juicy milkers oh my god man
don't care mommy milky mommy milky just
it's not fair it's not fair you can't
say that [ __ ]
it's not fair yeah cause that's the
funniest [ __ ] phrase and it's so
[ __ ] up the way they're using it
i know